Kim Petra speaking German my Dolph
quiver
my busy doth quick as a tongue breaker
it does
I remember said it's iconic I like doth
though I might start saying doll for fun
so thank you for the advice like
honestly I've lost my German accent so
much like I kind of want it back because
like whenever you hear another person
have an accent I'm like that's hot it
just left my body at some point and I
don't know why I need to work on that
thank you for reminding me keeping me on
my toes you inspired me today
yeah Deutsche Queen get up they don't
really say go off but yeah would be the
German version just for all of you who
don't know German I'ma shut up now shut
up okay